if you don't think this thing is
ratcheting up check this video out so
this is Vladimir Putin at a Russian
event this is with a whole bunch of
government officials and they are
announcing he's announcing the
suspension of the Strategic offensive
weapons treaty let me repeat what that
is the Strategic offensive weapons
weapons to attack people they are
suspending their involvement in the
Strategic offensive weapons treaty take
a look
thank you
[Applause]
is
just to be clear that the guy that was
circled there in the green that was we
grabbed this from Twitter that that's
Sergey lavrov he is the foreign minister
of Russia he's under personal sanctions
from the EU the United States United
Kingdom Canada Japan and Australia all
because of their invasion in 2022. uh he
was circled in that video for a separate
reason that someone was commenting on on
Twitter uh but this is the last
anti-nuke treaty between Russia and the
west and they are pulling out of it they
are saying we are not going to be part
of this anymore let me be clear as Joe
Biden often says I am not pro-putin I'm
not pro-russia and I don't think you can
just March your troops into someone
else's country and say we're taking this
land even if we think it was ours and
blah blah blah blah
and I don't think he's a friend of the
West and I don't think he's a friend of
minorities in all of those things but do
you see what is happening here we are on
the slow March being cheered on by the
entire Democrat Party and then every
time a republican comes out say DeSantis
or say certainly say Trump or or any of
these people at this point I don't think
Vivek and we'll see about Nikki Haley I
don't well Nikki Haley may be a little
more in the fight them directly that's a
so there is a split there in the
Republican so I think Nikki would be in
a little more of you fight them I know
she would be I've interviewed her about
it and uh and Pompeo former Secretary of
State he said on my show a couple weeks
ago you have to keep arming them so
there is a split but it's healthy to
have a split on a side like that's how
you debate things that's how you figure
things out but the point is every
Republican and not just Republican every
sane voice on television that is
anti-war anti just oh give him three
more tanks that'll that'll really tilt
the thing you always see this thing like
whoa we gave him five more plays oh oh
oh gosh they've got five more planes
this thing's over no no
it's not how it works they will try to
frame you as a stooge and a puppet and
you're somehow anti-American and you're
pro-russia and all that stuff as we just
inch closer and closer to World War III
[Music]